Trascrizione: Laura Leotta
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Guardate questa immagine.
Scommetto che,
se chiedessi ad uno di voi
di dirmi cosa vede,
probabilmente mi direbbe
"un trapano collegato a una siringa".
E se vi dicessi, invece,
che è un'apparecchiatura all'avanguardia
per il trattamento delle ferite?
So che sembra impossibile:
eppure, questo è il primo prototipo
della macchina che ho sviluppato,
insieme a due amici,
durante l'ultimo anno di università.
Sono una biotecnologa
con la passione per la stampa 3D;
e sono convinta che questa,
applicata alla biologia,
possa supportarla
in molteplici delle sue sfide.
Così, insieme a Riccardo e Valentina,
due compagni di università,
iniziamo a sviluppare
una stampante 3D un po' speciale,
che fosse in grado di estrudere
non solo plastiche,
ma anche cellule e biomateriali.
Terminato lo sviluppo di questa macchina,
ci troviamo in realtà
con due cose importanti.
La prima è la gastrite,
perché avevamo investito
tutto quello che avevamo
per realizzare la macchina,
e per mesi siamo andati avanti
con pasta aglio, olio e peperoncino;
e dall'altro lato,
ci troviamo con un bel soprammobile.
Qui la bellezza è soggettiva:
però, per noi era solo un soprammobile.
Infatti, a casa non avevamo né cellule
né biomateriali per poterla testare.
Così, decidiamo di rivolgerci
all'unico soggetto che conoscevamo
e che aveva accesso
a ciò di cui avevamo bisogno,
ossia l'università.
Facciamo vari tentativi:
eppure, non troviamo il supporto
che cercavamo e che ci aspettavamo.
Pensate che chiedevano soldi
a noi, per fare ricerca.
Finché non incontriamo
il professor Stefano Grolli,
e tutto il suo team.
Il prof ci accoglie nel suo dipartimento,
ci ascolta e comprende
le potenzialità di questa macchina.
Dal suo lato, il prof ci fa scoprire
il mondo degli emocomponenti,
ossia del sangue e dei suoi derivati.
Pensate a quante volte vi siete feriti,
e da solo il vostro organismo è guarito.
Il merito è del sangue:
In particolar modo,
a giocare un ruolo centrale
sono le piastrine,
questi minuscoli frammenti cellulari
che entrano in gioco
come primi soccorritori.
Le piastrine vanno ad aderire
nella zona del vaso che si è lesionata,
e attivano tutta una serie
di "fattori della coagulazione",
molecole segnale che concorrono
alla formazione del coagulo.
Il coagulo ha due funzioni:
la prima è quella
di bloccare il flusso ematico;
e l'altra è proprio quella di attivare
tutti i processi
di rigenerazione del tessuto.
Le potenzialità degli emocomponenti
hanno aperto la strada
a trattamenti medici innovativi:
gli scienziati hanno cercato di sfruttare
il potere delle piastrine,
e dei fattori di crescita
in esso contenuti,
per migliorare e promuovere
i processi di rigenerazione,
come nel caso delle ferite croniche.
Quando parlo di "ferite croniche",
parlo di piaghe da decubito,
ulcere diabetiche:
ossia, ferite che non riescono
a guarire da sole.
Pensate che solo in Italia
sono oltre due milioni
le persone che ne soffrono,
e che devono sottoporsi molto spesso
a trattamenti non risolutivi,
e molto dolorosi.
Nonostante il largo impiego
degli emocomponenti in questo ambito,
questi continuano ad avere
dei grossi limiti.
E sono legati: da un lato,
a quella che è la variabilità
nella lavorazione del sangue stesso;
e dall'altro lato, alla manipolazione
perché il sangue è liquido.
Perciò, pensate di mettere
qualcosa di liquido su una lesione:
ovviamente, questo non resterà lì,
e tenderà a cadere.
E quindi, l'efficacia
del trattamento verrà meno.
Ed è proprio qui,
che entriamo in gioco noi.
Con la nostra stampante,
abbiamo sviluppato uno "scaffold",
ossia una sorta di impalcatura
che intrappola il sangue
e lo rende solido,
migliorando quelle che sono
le caratteristiche intrinseche
del sangue stesso.
Risolto, quindi, il problema
della consistenza della manipolazione,
restava il problema della variabilità.
Legata non solo all'operatore
che prepara l'emocomponente,
ma legata anche al fatto
che ognuno di noi è diverso,
quindi il sangue di ogni paziente
ha caratteristiche diverse.
Quindi, abbiamo capito
che dovevamo realizzare un sistema
che standardizzare
la lavorazione del sangue.
Ed è qui che nasce Ematic.
Ematic è la macchina
che vi ho fatto vedere all'inizio:
non avevamo risorse,
eppure dovevamo dimostrare
che la nostra idea funzionava,
che avremmo potuto rivoluzionare
il settore della cura delle ferite.
Perciò mettiamo insieme un trapano,
una siringa e delle sacche,
e iniziamo a raccogliere
dei primi dati in vitro da poter mostrare.
Con questi dati andiamo dalle banche,
che ovviamente non aspettavano nient'altro
che tre giovani, senza lavoro né garanzie,
per concedere loro un mutuo.
Ovviamente, la strada delle banche
non è andata bene.
Abbiamo deciso perciò di andare
su un'altra strada,
quella degli investitori.
Ma sei anni fa, quando siamo partiti,
il mondo delle startup in Italia
era ancora un mondo embrionale,
e a maggior ragione
nell'ambito dell'healthcare.
Tre ricercatori
al di fuori dell'università,
senza un brevetto
e con un laboratorio in casa,
difficilmente infondono fiducia.
Perciò, anche questa strada
non andò bene subito.
Capimmo che dovevamo aumentare
la nostra credibilità,
che dovevamo anche acquisire
delle competenze manageriali,
che non avevamo come biotecnologi.
Così iniziammo a partecipare
a dei percorsi di accelerazione,
fatti apposta per le startup.
E in uno di questi, per fortuna,
abbiamo incontrato Andrea Chiesi
della Chiesi Farmaceutici.
Andrea si appassiona al progetto,
ne comprende quelle che sono
le basi tecnico-scientifiche.
e diventa nostro advisor.
In quel momento,
la nostra credibilità è cambiata:
siamo riusciti a trovare finanziatori,
abbiamo avuto modo
di avviare la nostra azienda
e finalmente terminare
lo sviluppo di Ematic,
realizzando quindi un sistema
completamente automatizzato
per il trattamento delle ferite.
Se da un lato Ematic
è stato molto complesso -
tutto quello che ha riguardato
il suo sviluppo ci ha provato -
dall'altro lato siamo riusciti
a realizzare un sistema molto semplice:
il medico effettua il prelievo
di sangue dal paziente,
lo inserisce all'interno della macchina
insieme a un kit monouso
che contiene lo scaffold;
e questo, in breve tempo,
restituisce il patch
pronto per essere applicato sulla lesione,
realizzando così una medicazione
personalizzata e riassorbibile.
I primi risultati positivi
sono arrivati dal settore veterinario.
Questo è Birba: è un labrador
con una ferita alla zampa
di oltre 20 centimetri.
Grazie ad Ematic, quindi
una sola applicazione del nostro patch,
in meno di tre mesi
la ferita è completamente guarita,
segno di come sia in grado di dimezzare
il tempo di guarigione delle lesioni
senza lasciare cicatrici.
In realtà, durante gli anni
di ricerca su Ematik
ci siamo resi conto
di come le sue proprietà
potevano dare beneficio
anche ad altri ambiti,
anche in altre applicazioni:
come nel caso della
ricrescita dei capelli,
nel trattamento ai tendini,
ai legamenti o nelle osteoartrosi,
ossia in tutte quelle patologie
in cui è necessario dare una spinta
al processo rigenerativo.
Questo ci ha insegnato come,
nel percorso verso una meta,
possano nascere delle nuove possibilità
altrettanto interessanti,
che dobbiamo sempre essere
pronti a cogliere.
Oggi sono orgogliosa di dirvi
che Ematic è ormai giunto al termine
del suo percorso regolatorio.
Questo significa che, a breve,
milioni di pazienti, finalmente,
ne potranno beneficiare.
Voglio lasciarvi con un disegno
preso da "Il Piccolo Principe".
Chi lo guarda, in realtà,
molto spesso non vede
nient'altro che un cappello.
In realtà, chi lo aveva disegnato
voleva raffigurare un boa
nell'atto di ingoiare
la propria preda, ossia un elefante.
L'augurio che voglio farvi
è quello che possiate vedere
anche voi il boa nell'elefante,
come noi siamo riusciti
a vedere Ematic in un trapano;
e di avere anche la forza e la caparbietà
di perseguire e realizzare la vostra idea.
Perché si può fare.
(Applausi)